to go down to two confounded - hi my
name is Ellen Bennett and I'm a chef
hi my name is marina and I'm nine years
old I'm gonna be here by myself and
Ellen's gonna be in another room telling
me what to do are you ready for this yes
let's do it okay see you soon
today we're gonna be making a cookie
recipe that I developed with dried
apricots sesame seeds pecans and a bunch
of other really delicious ingredients at
home I do not bake a lot from scratch
I've done my easy bake one I made icing
in it and it didn't work out I burned it
I have a lot of friends that have kids
and I like to cook with their kids but
this is the first time I've ever done it
in a sort of professional setting
okay marina can you hear me yeah are you
ready yes are you so excited yes you
need to do a little jiggle just to get
out all the Shakey's okay perfect
let's do this so I want you to grab the
flour the baking soda and the salt yeah
okay got them perfect so I put the whole
thing of the flour the whole thing okay
you've got this okay keep going don't
even worry about making a mess let Julie
click Next Next
take those two little guys the baking
soda and then the salt awesome
next we're gonna use that big giant red
standing mixer lift it open yep and now
I want you to take the butter and see
that red spatula on the right yes you're
gonna take it and you're going to scrape
it into the big giant standing mixer
you're good
perfect okay now you're gonna grab the
brown sugar and the white sugar and
that's the one you want to put that
whole thing in first steps completed so
now
quality control how's the quality on
that sugar really good those chocolate
chips look like they need some
inspection can't get in there what do
you think boss good good checks so now
you're gonna close up that mixer so I
want you to turn it on for about two
okay you're gonna let that go and go and
find the vanilla find the vanilla
extract found it so we're not gonna add
it until it gets creamy okay okay I have
not used the mixer before I thought I
was just gonna use spoon to mix
everything but the mixer is easier turn
it off now grab your red spatula and now
you're just gonna push along the side so
we make sure that all the butter and
sugar is combined does it look combined
yes fluffy yeah it's really fluffy so
now we're going to take the vanilla
extract and put it in there and mix it
for about 30 seconds okay
[Music]
at first I didn't quite know what she
was doing and then I realized she's just
counting I love that I love that she was
just she figured out her own tactic she
figured out her own way and she made it
work it's been 30 seconds okay turn it
off okay how's it looking does it look
fine
yes perfect best student ever am I your
only student yeah
next up find the egg kay found it now
you're gonna take one of those bowls
right in front of you and you're gonna
crack it in there okay little harder
okay got it perfect so now we're going
to add that to your mix so we're going
to turn it on
perfect now go ahead and add that egg
okay wide it in the mixer is really
mixing it really good go to work mixer
we're gonna let it go a little bit
longer okay yeah we're gonna take that
big bowl of all of our what did we call
all those ingredients on them on the
right side the drying feeding bingo and
you're gonna pour them all in at once a
little bit did fall out okay go to work
okay so grab the bench scraper and just
scrape up that last bit of flour I
didn't know what a bench scraper was it
made things a lot easier than just
scraping it with my hand we're gonna mix
it for about a minute here you and four
but start at two okay
to go down to to compounded - I was
actually doing to settle down to one
when the flower went out of the mixer I
didn't know that was supposed to happen
and I creamed it down to one and then
stuff got way easier good thinking on
your toes that was great pivoting and
being flexible in the kitchen is super
important because you just never know
what's gonna come up and she just knew
you know what it's too fast I'm gonna
turn it down a little bit and those are
just little notches of confidence that
she's gaining we are going to add all
those ingredients you see there
remember the chocolate chips you
inspected earlier yes and the dried
apricots that you inspected earlier yeah
so we want to throw all of those in now
the pecan wheat germ it was so fun
seeing her try all these new things that
she's never seen before and then she
would taste it and she's gonna see all
the different variety that she can use
in a cookie and you could just tell that
she was feeling more and more
comfortable every step of the way okay
you can turn it off now there's a lot of
chunks so many chunk ingredients that we
put in that looks really good it does
what we're gonna do now is we're going
to chill the dough get that little red
spatula and I want you to scrape off
everything that's stuck to that paddle
well there's a lot of things stuck in it
and now you can go on the site yup you
got it you're so good I learned from the
best
I never knew I could actually bake and
you're really good at it that's a bit
surprising she is really funny and I
liked how she guides me through
everything that's a lot of dough yeah we
made a lot of cookie dough now it looks
kind of different than how it was before
isn't that amazing
yeah you did that I can't believe I did
it I'm giving you ten gold stars in the
air right now I'm giving you ten gold
stars for helping me oh right I think
that's it all right we'll take that to
the fridge ask
Camarena let's do this we're gonna make
some cookie balls grab that scooper get
in there roll that together pretend like
it's play-doh I love playing the
play-doh
me too you're gonna take those white
sesame seeds and the black sesame seeds
mix them together awesome now give it a
little shake of root now you're gonna
put that ball in there and just coat it
with sesame seeds okay
it's like sprinkles but healthier and
more texture now put that on your Scylla
back a little bit in yeah yep perfect I
made a snowman with them I love it but I
have to separate them it's true they can
come together later I'm gonna make the
biggest cookie do it do it
Wow I think I got too much this one
needs a lot of sesame seen a lot of
sesame food that one might take a bit
longer to bake because it's so much
bigger than all the other ones yeah a
lot Baker a little bigger so now we're
gonna put it in the oven and we're gonna
bake it for about 10 to 12 minutes and
we want it to be golden brown a little
bit squish in the middle but not too
squishy yeah all right take those
cookies and head to the oven okay I'll
be here okay all right Marino let's do
this last step you're gonna scoop them
up and put them on the cooling rack okay
okay I got it okay and now my last
really big one are you ready to come out
and taste these cookies yes I'm coming
Maryna you did it oh we nailed it thank
you I'm so excited to try these are you
yes as professional residents of the
kitchen it's important that we plate
them got a little plate and then last
but not least milk get in there you're
the expert mmm do you feel that texture
nice and soft in the middle grab your
cookie
okay I'm gonna grab my cookie Cheers to
successful cooking together okay that
was really good this was delicious you
did such a good job Thanks
I think marinas on the right track to
doing a lot more baking in her future I
could tell there was a sparkle in her
eye I would give Ellen a hundred gold
stars for how good she did I do think we
make a good team my name is Owen Bennett
and I am a chef
my name is marina and I'm now a chef too
[Music]